- A girl like me, I'll be honest with you,
they say the transgender girl
that makes the most money
out here is me.
The white girl with the big dick.
I wanna be frank with you,
it's exactly what they say.
The white girl with the big dick
makes the most money
'cause that's what they want.
Sometimes I feel like being homeless,
well, of course it doesn't
give you curb appeal
to passerbyers, but it
ruins all the good looks.
Everything beautiful you have about you.
It ruins your feet.
It's hard to shave.
And people walk by,
and they make fun of you.
Sometimes other races
who are trying to get social acceptance
make fun of you and don't realize that,
you know, how hurtful that is.
And it's getting more dangerous
with all of the homeless being
put in shelter in places.
And the only people left out
are the people that are too crazy
to be able to be put in shelter in places.
So there's no one to talk to,
no one to hang out with.
And if you try to hang out with someone,
they wind up crazy,
and you wind up having to mace them.
Or going out to the ho stroll,
sometimes you feel like
the only people left to pick
you up are serial killers.
There's no one out there
prostituting with you,
so you feel like if you were to disappear,
no one would even know.
It's hard to make money.
It's sucks.
And,
I've been a little suicidal sometimes.
Freezing my nuts off
every night 'cause it's San Francisco.
I think I'm stuck.
I did get hit in the head
after I saw y'all last.
This guy hit me in the back of
the head with a two by four.
Like it was like a stick,
a really long stick.
It was like broke off
of a two by four, and,
and he hit me really hard,
and he hit me so hard I almost
hit my face on the concrete
'cause I was sitting down Indian-style,
Or let's be proper and
say Native American-style.
But he hit me so hard
in the back of the head
that I almost hit my face concrete.
And I wound up in the hospital again,
filed a police report,
told them who it was, where he hangs out
and they never did anything.
They never went and arrested him.
They never did a stay
away order or anything.
I changed my services
from the clinic I was at
because I, I feel like they
weren't doing anything for me.
I feel like I'm gonna be the last person
out here on the streets.
I'm lonely,
I'm tired,
I'm broke,
I'm homeless,
and I feel empty on the inside.
But I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I fucking don't have a phone.
My parents disowned me.
All my family disowned me
back in January,
they waited til my mom died.
She died of brain cancer.
And then they were like,
well, mom gave me everything,
and we don't have to give you nothing.
And with that said,
the rest of the family disowns you.
And I was like,
I didn't know what to think about it.
I mean,
it was fucked up.
And I, and they even said things like,
well, you didn't love mom anyway.
I was like, how can you say that?
I was like, that's horrible.
I mean, of course, I loved mom.
I mean, she loved coming down
to New Orleans to see me,
and we had such a great time.
Of course, I just wound
up telling my sister that
that I hope that everything she left you
brings you all the joy in life
and everything you've ever wanted,
including a new sister.
And then I just blocked 'em,
and gave 'em no avenue to find me.
And I tried to find the peace in it.
I tried to find the
positive and the negative.
And,
use it maybe as a drive to keep going.
And I figured since that was the case,
and they disowned me,
that I would finish my transition
and make sure that they don't even as much
as recognize me when I get done
because if they don't want me,
then I don't want them
to be able to find me.
And I figured I'd make my own family,
but it's so hard to make a
family out here with anybody.
'Cause everyone's got ulterior motives.
Not that ulterior motive is bad at all,
it's the type of ulterior
motive people have.
You know, nothing's free,
especially for a girl.
I mean, if a girl wants something,
she's always got to put out for it.
You know,
people are selfish.
I mean, nothing is free here.
You know, and all I, all I
really want, you know, is
I figured by now I would
have met some guy who's like,
ah, she's the kindness in the air.
I'm okay. I'm okay.
Sees how sweet I am.
And would have maybe scooped me up by now.
And told me something like,
I wish I would have met you sooner.
But it hasn't.
Sometimes I just want to
jump in a hole and hide.
I don't understand it.
But I'll keep trying.
You know, there's no place for me to go.
There's no place left.
San Francisco is it.
I'm too old to keep traveling.
I don't want to travel anymore.
It took me six months to trek out here.
That was the last best
time I can remember.
I was traveling out here from
San Fran, from New Orleans.
I jumped on a getting company
tour with my friend, Shiva.
Our car broke down in Arizona.
I hopped a freight with
a guy named Possum,
some chick from Tennessee
and the chihuahua.
We got thrown off the train in the desert,
walked a little ways to a truck stop
after BNSF agreed not
to file charges on us
for hopping a freight.
And it was the last fun time I ever had.
I've been,
I love it here.
Don't get me wrong.
I love San Francisco.
There's a lot of times
out here I'm miserable
and unhappy.
But I'm stuck here.
And,
I feel like
this place has disabled me.
In what way, I'm not really sure.
It's caught, it's got
me caught up in drugs,
prostitution.
Sometimes I hate my life.
I wonder how it all came-
(Stephanie crying)
I wonder how it all came to this.
Sometimes it takes me, it
takes everything in me to-
I still have the want and
the drive and the ambition,
but I'm just so fucking tired.
I would sometimes just rather
lay the fuck around
than carry on.
But if I lay around then
people stare at you,
and they walked by and they laugh at you,
and they snicker amongst themselves
about what's wrong with you
instead of like,
helping,
walking through it with you.
You know,
I think if I asked somebody
to walk through it with me,
don't have to do it for me,
just walk with me, hang
out with me through it,
it would give me what I needed
to accomplish the things
that I need to,
knowing that I have
somebody there at my side
to hang out with me while
I'm getting it done.
And kind of like,
cheering me on,
being a little positive minion.
You know?
I don't know.
Either way,
I don't see that I have any other choice.
You know, what am I going to do?
Commit suicide?
I mean, come on.
That would never happen.
If anybody ever said I committed
suicide, they're lying.
'Cause I would never do that.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I really wouldn't.
Believe me.
I stay away from the right drugs.
Like I don't shoot.
I hate needles.
Can't stand them.
They terrify me.
Not even a nurse can barely even stick me.
I don't do Fentanyl.
I don't do heroin.
I don't smoke crack.
You can't pay me to do it.
Regretfully, I do crystal.
I smoke weed.
And that's it.
There is nothing else.
But I do the drugs I do
because of my traumas.
I won't go to a rehab
because they're almost just as exhausting
as it, being on the streets are, for me,
because I don't care for
the principles behind it,
Narcotics Anonymous.
They tell you to demolish
all of your friendships
and things like that.
Quit talking to everyone.
And I just don't believe in that.
You know, I, I don't
really have friends anyway.
If you really think about it,
when I have a cell phone, it's pointless.
'Cause my phone never rings.
No one ever calls me.
I could have a hundred phone numbers,
and no one will ever call me.
I've always the one to call people.
You know?
Friends are supposed to, like, call you
and want to hang out with you
and want to invite you over,
and they say, what can I do for you?
You know, but it's always,
Hey, can I get this?
Can I get that?
Hey, da da da da da.
But no one ever rings my phone.
And that's how I know
I don't have friends.
And that's lonely, and
no one does deserve that.
You know?
You know, I feel better that I cried.
Got it all out.
But,
I got many more tears
before it all comes out,
you know.
I don't ever get to talk to anyone.
You know, I, I, I don't
ever get to cry to anyone.
It's always me and myself.
You know, I just, I'm so
fortunate that being out here
and going through all
this hasn't made me crazy.
I can't imagine going crazy.
You know, I, just things
I see people do out here
that are fucking crazy.
I mean, please, if you ever see me
doing any of those things,
please shoot me on the site.
Please put me on my misery
because I mean, I get embarrassed
a lot out here and ashamed,
and I don't like people
seeing me like this.
You know, people go, who gives
a fuck what people think?
Well, I do.
I do give a fuck what people think.
I don't give a fuck who
you are, where you're from.
I give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
'Cause I wasn't raised that way.
And I do care.
I don't want people to see me like this.
I don't want people to
see me on the street,
sitting on a sidewalk,
starving, hungry, begging.
I hate that shit.
I hate it with a purple passion.
You know,
I feel like being transgender
affects me getting jobs.
I've tried to get a job
in the last few weeks,
and I've got nothing.
I,
I've even been having
people telling me lately
that I should get in boy form.
And I don't want to.
I don't want to.
You know, I, I'm not a boy,
and they go, well to move up
in a better position in life,
sometimes you have to.
No, I don't.
I don't have to.
And I'm not going to.
You know?
I'm either going to get, get, it.
Get the things I need,
move into the better
position in life like this,
or I guess I'm not going to at all.
You know?
Because I know me.
I can get in boy form, sure.
But as soon as I get an itch,
I'm going to get right back in girl form,
and the mother fuckers that
I was sitting here dressing
up in boy form for, to please them,
they're going to catch me a girl form
at one point or another.
And when they do,
cat's out of the bag,
and it'll all come crashing down anyway.
So I might as well stay
in my comfortable form.
You know, I'm, I'm, I'm
a transgender woman,
and if they don't like it,
they can suck my tranny dick.
'Cause that's what I tell them all.
You know, excuse my language.
But that's, that's my favorite saying
for those that don't like me.
Although I joke and
tease about it sometimes,
but,
I feel like I'm rambling.
- [Interviewer] Beautiful talk.
- [Stephanie] Thank you.
I appreciate it.
- [Interviewer] You did a great job.
- [Stephanie] And I appreciate y'all too.
Y'all are amazing.
You know.
- [Interviewer] I'm so
glad I found you again.
- [Stephanie] I'm so glad to be found.
It's good to be seen,
to know I'm alive and to be around.
- [Interviewer] It's nice
to let you share your stuff.
- [Stephanie] Yeah. For sure.
It's good to get out a few tears.
You know,
it's not good to bottle
that stuff in though.
You know?
- [Interviewer] That's got to be terrible.
- [Stephanie] Yeah. And you'll help me out
amazingly considering
between now and tomorrow,
I don't know how to
figure out my pin number,
but I might have to go back
to the general assistance office,
which is all I get.
I get like 588 a month and
200, $200 in food stamps.
And I have to make that
last an entire month.
And that's fucking very difficult.
I don't get social security.
I don't get any other income.
- [Interviewer] What about
some of the guys you date?
- [Stephanie] So the guys that I date,
oh, I can tell you about them.
Usually they're married men,
or they have ex wives and kids,
or sometimes they're drug dealers,
but none of them, they all
have one thing in common.
None of them wants you
to reveal their secrets.
to act like you know them
if you see them on the street.
And some people are willing
to go crazy distances
to hide those secrets.
You know, they say, so if you see me,
if, if you see me on the
street, do you know me?
I've been asked that before
by scary drug dealers and everything,
and I go, nope, don't know you
Never seen you.
However, if you're, if they're alone,
they might say you can say hi.
And I've been in that situation too.
But they get really fucking nervous.
Like, I've even,
I was in a shelter in place at one time,
but somebody had taken my silicone breasts
because my breasts are growing,
and I'm on the pills,
so they take a long time to grow.
And I get very self-conscious,
so I wear a silicone fillers.
Somebody had taken them at
the shelter in place I was at,
which wasn't funny.
And
I tripped out about it
because that's like
stealing my prosthetics.
That's part of my
identity, and I need that.
I feel like I need it
to survive.
You know,
to feel as real as possible.
And I tripped out about it.
I did what anybody would do.
I didn't lash out at anyone.
I didn't curse anyone out.
I've just had an anxiety
attack, and they threw me out.
And, like I had accumulated
a good bit of clothes
and shoes and everything.
My feet were back to normal.
I was getting clean, smooth
shaves and everything.
And then it all went down and drain.
I couldn't carry clothes,
so I had to get rid of them.
And then I realized I still had too much,
and I had to get rid of them.
And I'm down to now
a pair of shoes, a pair of
boots, pairs of stilettos,
neither one in which are good for my feet,
as you can see.
My right foot,
at times I feel like I can't feel my toes.
I'm down to
a couple of mini dresses and a mini skirt,
maybe three mini dresses.
Nothing which but one is a
long sleeve, and it's lace.
No tent, no sleeping bag, no blanket.
'Cause I'm too bougie to carry
that shit around with me.
You'll never catch me pushing
in a basket down the street,
bitch, fuck.
But at the same time, at nighttime,
- [Interviewer] It's so cold right?
- I'm freezing to death.
And I'm a cuddler,
so I, you know, I like it warm as it is.
So the slightest cold makes
me feel like I'm freezing.
And sometimes it's near impossible
to find a way to cover up.
And like, I mean, even ambulances
won't even pull over for you.
Like, I've caught them at red lights,
and they just sped off on me.
when I tried to get a blanket.
You know, I've almost went
to the hospital in lied
and said that I was suicidal,
just so I can get somewhere warm to sleep.
And people are careless as
if it's always your fault
that you're out here.
And I got news for you.
I mean, we all play a
little part in everything,
but it's not always your
fault that you're out here.
I came out here because a friend
asked me to come out here.
I was supposed to be set
up with a place to stay,
and when I got out here, it
wound up not being what it was.
And it wind up putting me
out here on the streets.
And being out in San
Francisco on the streets,
and trying to get on my feet,
has been, hands down, the hardest place
I've ever tried to get on my feet before.
'Cause people here,
maybe it's the locals
are the friendly ones
and the foreigners are not.
All I know is people out
here are not as friendly as,
people are not as friendly
anywhere as they used to be.
Doors do not open as
freely as they used to.
Anytime they catch a
person sleeping somewhere,
and they move you a week later,
they'll come and fix the
fence the whole area off.
Everything's locked down,
everything's fenced down.
And you know, I'm just,
I'm lucky to be alive.
That's just it.
You know?
Yeah. But the guys are
pretty much sweet out here.
A girl liked me,
I'll be honest with you.
They say the transgender
girl that makes the
most money out here is me.
The white girl with the big dick.
I want to be frank with you.
It's exactly what they say.
The white girl with a big
dick makes the most money
because that's what they want.
However,
I get a lot of guys that
just try to take advantage.
They try to throw me spiels
like, Oh, I'm new at this.
Sure you are.
Now, I'm sure you got
coached by your friend,
who tells you if you come
out to the ho stroll,
pretty much you should know the prices.
You know, you should
know that you don't come
to ho stroll and pickup a ho for free.
You know, but my problem is
I just get a bunch of guys who
want to take advantage of me.
That's all they ever want.
They want to go 20 bucks, 40 bucks.
No, ma'am.
No, sir.
Sorry.
No.
I'm worth more than that.
I deserve better.
You know, and those who treat
me that way should be ashamed
of theirself.
You know?
And it's an insult, you know?
Because I'm sorry,
but having sex with all of these men,
it's just too much work
for that amount of money.
They expect too much for too little.
And afterwards,
don't get me wrong,
ain't no girl could probably sit there
and say otherwise neither.
We've all been desperate
one time or another.
You know, and from that
experience, afterwards,
when all they give you is
like 20 bucks or something,
makes you feel like shit.
Makes you feel horrible.
And it's unfair.
And I don't appreciate it.
So usually after the first
guy tries to run game on me,
it usually kills the whole
wanting to hang out at the ho stroll.
Usually I'll just wander off.
And girls telling me all
the time, they're like,
you just be patient.
You just tell them no.
And they'll drive around
the block a few times.
They'll come back, and
they'll pay you the price,
but I don't even want it.
I don't even want to ho.
I don't even want it.
Definitely don't want a
ho after the first one
tries to run game
because I tell him no.
And then by that point,
my feet are killing me
because I'm too antsy.
You're not going to catch
me standing in one spot.
You know, I, I walk slowly.
You know, but yeah,
that's about how it is, you know.
But eventually, yeah, it's true.
You'll meet a guy eventually,
and he'll grow a liking to you.
However, I'm a white girl.
All of them grow attached to me.
A couple of them,
I had one get possessive,
stabbed me in the knee with a syringe.
I don't, luckily I don't
have HIV or, or Hep C.
I, I did just get a STD cured,
but I'm lucky I haven't caught HIV.
You know what I mean?
Because I would just die.
The way I'm terrified of needles.
I can't promise you I could do it.
And I would probably die.
And that's the honest truth.
They would have to have a
live in nurse live in with me
and make sure that I, I take my shots
and go in for my levels and stuff
because I can't promise you,
being that I'd have to go in
for blood levels that often,
that I could do it.
I mean, they have to chase me as it is
just to get me to go into
the clinic and get a shot.
So I guess I could, one thing
I could change about my life
is I could start being more careful.
Because I'm not the most
careful girl I know.
So does that wrap up our session?
- [Interviewer] It does.
- Alright.
- [Interviewer] Stephanie,
good talking to you.
- Love y'all.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.
- Okay. And y'all on camera, too.
- [Interviewer] You're so cute.
- [Stephanie] Oh, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.
- [Stephanie] For sure.
Do some of the girls hit on you?
I know they have to,
but you're a handsome guy.
- [Interviewer] I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm all business when I'm doing this.
- [Stephanie] And you should be, you know.